Scientific notation is written in a very specific form. So people all over the
world can compare numbers that are really large or really small. That form is a
times 10 to the b. Note this x here denotes mulitiplication. It is not a
variable. This formula requires that this first number here is a number between
1, which included, and 10, not included. And then this is multiplied by integer
power of 10. So an example of something like this would be 5.6 times 10 to the
2. Notice that 5.6 is in fact a number between 1 and 10. This is something we
need to be very careful about. And it's easy to make a mistake. For example, we
can make one very small change. If instead, we have 56 times 10 to the 2, we
are no longer writing in scientific notation. 56 is not between 1 and 10. Now
I'm going to write down several numbers. And I'd like you to tell me, which of
them are not written in the proper form for scientific notation? We have 5
times 10 to the 12th, 6.543 times 10 to the negative 4, 6 times 10 to the 6.5,
1.2 times 100 to the 4th, 0.5 times 10 to 3rd, 4 times 2 to the 6th. And last
but not least, 325 times 10 to the negative 7.